all right let's go with E for this time
enough of D for by the way any of you
think we're gonna see a four in the next
game in the twelfth game I doubt it
actually you know what it might be
played it might be played yeah it might
be played efore and then C will have the
Petroff I'll be interesting could also
turn out to be not so interesting going
back on my words there could be
interesting could not be interesting so
here we have the right Lopez and they're
calling this the birds defense 94 is the
birds defense
yepper I don't know my openings I was
just reading a castle let's not castle
just take this night that can't be bad
can it its castle
um back up yeah is there's this pawn
sack it really shouldn't work out
alright let's reinforce my Center I
might also want to play c3
man hmm
what do I do here
you see here's one thing if I play e5 my
Bishop is kind of dead I'm biting on a
rock I play here I'm still biting on a
rock and how do i crack at this
structure how do i how do i free my
bishop
I don't know to do here if I take then I
help the knight develop I'd rather not
help the knight develop hmm
I'm up that reinforced this pond I'd
much rather take after this night has
moved I don't want to help black develop
I don't want to take here while the
night is still on this square and I
think I want to make another purposeful
move and I think rook here is at seeing
how this is well if I really want to
make it it's gonna be a completely open
file black cannot avoid that
so another purposeful move and can black
be make okay I don't have any choice
that's come here now maybe I could go
with a for threatened and maybe open up
that a file can black make another
purposeful move or is that night going
to move or is black gonna go with g6 to
develop the bishop but going with the g6
means what what does that mean it means
f6 is weak maybe I don't take still and
instead run with just night here I think
I'm in a better position to be making
purposeful moves and right now there's
maybe some lines where I could be
throwing in 95 with tempo on the Queen
the position can open up very quickly
black is lagging and development I'm two
moves away from being fully developed
and now I could consider taking here and
I probably should
before my bishop gets crunched as a
follow-up
I think Knight g5 is the way to go with
pretty serious threat of taking here and
then Queen checks and maybe picking off
a piece should there be g6 it might be
the situation where if the Queen comes
out and gives check the King would have
to run instead of g6 but we're not
having that
okay kicking a tempo on the Queen and
then take if I take right now the Queen
has to recapture but maybe I could first
give a tempo gain a tempo with 95 and
then take right there also be something
with night here and then Knight takes
pawn huh this half this right here has
to be uncomfortable I'm gonna go with it
because where does the Queen go she has
to still keep a close eye on the knight
and the bishop excuse me because if the
knight ever moves those discovered stuff
so all right
hmm
the Queen has to make a move that
defends the bishop I think this is the
only move I was just seeing something
like Queen here something like some like
cross pin ooh wait a second there might
be something there that might turn out
to be a pretty slick move oh this might
work Knight takes f7 Bishop takes Bishop
there's a fork on d6 Knight takes if the
King takes I have Queen here check
no that's probably not working something
with my back rank I think Knight takes
King takes Queen check there's too much
to calculate because there could also be
Bishop recaptures yeah I'm not really
seeing it so let's not do it it's not
dude things you can't calculate
completely through
I should probably also consider my time
is low low on time let's do this
whoa I just dropped my g2 pun no I
didn't I'm on em my heart did skip a
beat
yep just develop quit getting fancy with
your silly little calculations here yeah
g2 it's okay
you can't take g2 because I'll take this
guy so I want to keep yeah sorry sorry
if I got out right there again don't
don't put those headphones away
um I don't know what to suggest for
black
hmm whoo this is actually working
pretty sure tricky stuff lateral
movement the pawn push I could actually
take the knight can't
I thought the knight can recapture but
it can't it's in a pin but even if it
could I have this Bishop has some
problems if the King moves here I take
the bishop first and then I land a fork
here then I take the Queen then the rook
in this order I think is best
take here give a check first there's
tension between the Queen's it's not
gonna be playing here no I have this
covered just for a second just for one
move
yeah yeah let me take care oh they're
getting my bishop though I better go
with it ah I might be losing two minor
pieces hang on not so clear Oh
if the bishop played here I think I end
up losing that though there's no time
though is there the Knights getting
kicked around pawn push keep the a file
closed all right this is locked up over
here and I don't I don't want to allow
the night there so let me inch my way up
a little bit just a little bit trade
rooks inch my way up still King position
just come over here get this move in
take with my rook okay now I have an
open file and I could pivot on this
square even if it's taken I could take
that night these pawns fast no time all
right good game mr. head BOGO let me go
back your flip I think I didn't I think
you ended up defending pretty good right
there like I thought I I thought surely
there was gonna be some knockout but I
think if you don't play your Bishop to
d6 I may be the the worst sight to be
honest that I think even getting in this
situation is kind of tough is Knight
here the move to go with should it be
pawn here immediately
maybe that's an adjustment and it would
make for smoother development because
there's only so many useful moves you
could make again I'm not taking cuz I'm
just helping you out and by not helping
you out
yeah it's awkward now to complete the
Kings side development so I
if you switch the move order in other
words I wonder if d5 and then maybe
Knight f6 is better
I'd consider this d5 move and then
Knight f6 Bishop e7 I think that that
might be an improvement but defended
well I didn't have a I didn't come
through with the knockout not here just
seemed way too appealing not to do umm
maybe there was something better here I
take you recaptured the Queen I give a
check you bump up oh I missed something
rook takes Knight and then I get the
Queen that was probably being typed in
the chat somewhere I wasn't looking at
it but now I'm sitting it rook takes
Knight and then take the Queen I was too
fixated I'm just grabbing this guy so a
blunder on my part right here I should
have taken the night and after you take
this I'm trying to rescue my knight
after rook here in Bishop here and wrote
to f8 I'm in some trouble I think I
don't know is there way you could rescue
it maybe with something like maybe I'd
be doing rook rook here and rook here in
the mean time but yeah I should have
taken the night with the check right
there and my earlier my early suggestion
I guess I'm the black side is to maybe
run with d5 first before declaring your
king knight's intentions